[Musica]
c'è qualcosa dentro alla scatola egisto
berlino
una sfera
vitale viene a vedere cosa ho trovato
dentro questa scatola
che cosa ho trovato il trono scatola uno
spera una bolla tu non lo sai che quella
scatola pericolosa prima di tutto dentro
non toccare nomi più
bella cosa ma che falsa pure scrittori e
non aprire chiudi chiudi va bene
ecco fatto l'ho chiusa non lato però più
che io adesso vado perché il suo mesi
brucia però non toccarlo casa dopo lo so
che vitale ha detto di non toccare la
scatola ma io sono troppo curioso che
cosa sarà questa sfera prendiamole
portiamolo in camera senza farsi
scoprire da vita mi
guarda berlino che cosa secondo te a me
sembra una semplice sfera di cristallo
guarda murray non li vedi anche tu
per gli effetti
forse una sfera magica
wow
sono bellissimi
pensi che stia cercando di comunicare
con noi marino
vuoi dirmi qualcosa dice che devo stare
attenta beh forse hai ragione ma mi
incuriosisce troppo così misteriosa
che c'è berlino non ti piace questa
sfera
ti sto preoccupando
sta antipatica questa sfera non mi dire
che la vuoi mangiare a
cominciare questa
sì
rumore sentito comune strano che cosa
stai facendo
niente una challenge
qui c'è qualcosa di sospetto miseria ha
niente di sospetto non c'è niente di
strano va bene comunque pro pochi minuti
è pronto io ti consiglio di arrivare per
tempo altrimenti mi spaziano tutto ciao
[Musica]
diventare
una di noi
che significa forse una di quelle sfere
che le scudi ti danno una risposta
proviamo
[Musica]
e tornata trasparente
sono giocattolo andiamocene
[Musica]
non sono un giocattolo che qualcosa di
strano con questa sfera non pensate
anche voi sembra che voglia comunicare
secondo voi dovrei fidarmi onu
[Musica]
che strano
mi sembrava di sentire un rumore
forse c'era anche una luce
ma mi sembra completamente vuota
che mal di schiena
[Musica]
che cos'è quest
in un'altra
niente stavo solo
giocando con berlino
tolgono rossi doria
vitale non deve scoprire che ho preso la
sfera merlino aiutami tu l'italia non
deve spettare ai ai carrino queste sono
le mie ali non puoi mangiarle mi fai
male deve esserci un modo di toglierle
spera e vera di cristallo
fammi tornare come prima giuro che non
dirò mai più che sei solo un giocattolo
peggio per te anita ormai è accettata la
sfida ora dovrai superare tutte le prove
a meno che non vorrei vivere con
lei
perché non si illuminò più appaiono più
le scritto non si sente niente non
succede niente e va bene c'è bisogno di
una misura drastica
vediamo se funziona
è impossibile toglierle devo trovare il
modo di comunicare componente con la
sfera state frati è una formula
fini tutto bene ma mi dire questo solo
giocando con berlino idea però
nascondere sotto questa coperta
niente ti ho detto sto giocando con
berlino stiamo costruendo una cosa
[Musica]
e perché una sorpresa
dov'è la sorpresa devo ancora prepararla
ma se questa cosa di vedere avevo freddo
quindi ho deciso di mettere una coperta
per ricevuto freddo ci
mostrano questa impalcatura invece qui è
la sorpresa la sorpresa ceo le sorprese
e ancora non è pronta lo scoprirai più
tardi che bello che bello che bello non
vedo l'ora allora
c'è mancato poco che scoprisse le oli e
vitale scopre che ho preso la sfera è
che ho causato questo strano maledizione
si arrabbierà tantissimo perché lui
aveva detto dall'inizio di non toccare
la sfera lo avrei dovuto ascoltare che
cosa vuoi da me che cosa devo fare
se proprio devo vivere con queste ali
almeno vi piacerebbe sapere se posso
volare
sarebbe un sogno poter volare come
un'idea senza farsi scoprire da vita ne
usciamo fuori vediamo se riusciamo a
volare con queste ali
almeno una cosa divertente di questa
maledizione
mi raccomando se non avete ancora
lasciato mi piace ma so di un mi piace
il clima di festa per donare
per l'impegno io
c'è un sacco di vento non so se riuscirò
a usare queste ali con questo vento
decisamente non riesco a volare
purtroppo è il tutto aumentando meglio
tornare dentro casa andiamo a no ragazzi
ora che faccio non riesco a toglier non
riesco neanche a volare che poteva
essere una cosa più divertente di avere
delle ali aveva ragione vitale non
dovevo prenderlo non dovevo toccarla ma
non si attiva più vedete forse devo
usare qualche sorta di parola magica
magari è usato una parola che l'ha
attivata
poco
e speriamo
[Musica]
che cosa stai facendo ma
cosa sono quelle è un costume di
carnevale il costume di carnevale in
anticipo per l'anno prossimo quella sera
si della sfera della scatola e va bene
sì l'ho presa ok è troppo curiosa
ero curiosa di vedere che cosa fosse
questo spero e qui passano avuto io ho
detto solo noto videogiocatore e allora
deve essersi arrabbiata per un pesce di
vera anche se non so come fare
arrabbiare la sfera comunque ma deciso
di trasformarmi in una fata o un insetto
attenta sempre annuali da fatto o alida
insetto da libellula è un incrocio tra
ali da farfalla e alida fatah
che non riesco a volare ma di
riempimento avevo detto di non toccare
questa sfera non hai ragione ma ora come
passo ho provato a toglierli nell'anima
talora innanzitutto non toccare più
quella sfera è la schabus
non posso vivere con queste ali non ti
preoccupare insieme troveremo una
soluzione
beh
potrebbero evitare
beh per i preti per la prima prova
mia cara fatine
di per un momento
divenne trovarti mia casa chi le
date per due e
sentite anche voi questi rumori
non mi dire te sono ancora i passi al
piano di sopra
[Musica]
chi evita le sei tu di tale sei tu
perchè non rispondi
non c'è nessuno da te
vitale sei tu perchè non rispondi
meglio trovare un nascondiglio e lo
svelto
nascondiamoci sotto al letto
[Musica]
[Applauso]
la gente
andate per fortuna possiamo uscire fuori
dal letto
guardate ha lasciato qualcosa questa
storia diversa da quella che ho trovato
dentro alla scatola ma quello che ho
trovato dentro la scatola non c'è più
l'ha sostituita con questa è molto più
piccola che cosa vorrà dire sì bella e
affascinante questa nuova sfera wi fi
nipote di toccarla
[Musica]
vita si sta facendo e ti devo spiegare
una cosa ti ricordi la scorza sfera che
mi ha fatto spuntare queste ali si me la
ricordo eccome beh è entrato qualcuno è
rubata e in cambio ha lasciato questa
sfera cosa è rientrato a cambiarla lo so
io mi sono nascosta sotto al letto sotto
al letto di specie di
detenuto che la nuova sfera a me sembra
una semplice sfera di cristallo
l'unica differenza con l'altra e che è
più piccola vero si è fatto è più
piccola è strana però penso che ci sia
niente che non va con questa sfera tu
credi che ci sia qualcosa che non va
pensi che ci sia una maledizione anche
in questa sfera
secondo me è meglio non fidarsi e quindi
che faccio la devo lasciare qua sopra
ok non posso neanche spostarla non posso
avvicinarmi
aspettiamo e vediamo che succede voi
cosa ne pensate secondo voi è pericolosa
anche questa sfera
non vuole toccare la nuova sfera
che cos'è questo rumore non vi conviene
barbie rb
qualcosa fuori in giardino
che cosa sta succedendo fuori in
giardino
penso che sia colpa di quella sfera si
si sta arrabbiando che cosa devo fare
allora forse devo per forza prendere la
nuova sfera altrimenti succederà
qualcosa in casa o fuori da casa meglio
di no altrimenti si sa in che cosa ti
trasforma quella nuova sfera nel i trim
estremi rimedi per
riprenderti mie che era pettini detti
cos'è quella luce lì qualcosa
vado io a controllare tu rimani qua e
pericoloso io vado a controllare veto se
c'è qualcosa là fuori prima di qua e
controlla la sfera ok ok stai attenta
però è
che cos'è
un biglietto
ai anita trovo dai preti quest'olio
chi è adesso sì
chi è
fatto ci piega ad aprire una porta
[Musica]
cos'è quello
albè buonasera un giorno come posso
aiutarla
[Musica]
chi sei
la fatina chi sei
o meglio cosa sei
la tua sfera perù che hai lasciato
quella sfera qui la luce proveniva da
questo biglietto vediamo cosa c'è
scritto
ma guarda io non so di che cosa stai
parlando non lo so proprio
che non si dica fatto parlare non so chi
sei tu ma io non hai visto
effettivamente una sfera
sì c'era una sfera 127 sì una sfera
c'era chi dice che non stai di corretto
parlando ma tu che cosa 66 una fata e
cosa pensi che figlia con queste hai una
mucca una zanzara ricetta che fanno una
fata ora dimmi tu video nove la mattina
e dove la aspetta aspetta aspetta allora
visto che sei una fata forse ci può
aiutare in pratica la mia ragazza ha
toccato questa sfera e all'improvviso ne
sono uscite le ali e si è trasformato in
fatta magari e tu ci può aiutare a farla
ritornare come era prima che crei pensi
dimmi solo dove la fatina
e
ancora peggio è che se il tuo fidanzato
vorrei salvare la nuova sfera dovrai
toccare o no forse vitale in pericolo è
meglio che torno subito da vitale di
rabbia non ti arrabbiare aspetta aspetta
aspetta riguarda solo un'altra domanda
da farsi e non riguarda la sfera è solo
una domanda che ho fin da quando era un
bambino non riesco proprio a togliermela
dalla testa questa domanda la fatina dei
denti v cosa se ne fa dei denti che
raccoglie ci fa una collana pure non lo
so magari fate le dentiere e poi magari
deciso di venderla magari vivono le
collanine rosso che fa sky perfetta
prova ancora un altro comando un'altra
domanda per favore non mi lascia altra
scelta per la curiosità che ha lottato
tutta un po perché stai piaciuto questo
impedito mister chiudendo le diede
vita
[Musica]
un po di stile per adesso
ecco la sfera chirico la sana
mio piccolino
l'aspettiamo
cm sorpresa inaspettata
[Musica]
che strisce de qua
combatti della zucchi essere rispettati
di trovarmi qui sei tu la fata della
sfera si siano proprio le porte per me
cantiere di co2 offerti tanti ne
dovrebbe isole che cosa ogni foto dove
sei invece solo per occupare di vita e
arezzo che come una entità sono sfere di
cristallo che solo che non può portarti
di persona potuto far sparire invita ora
dello stato non ti preoccupare vengono
riapparire detto che marittime ai last
stand
brivido perché non ho fatto
ma cosa succederà se tocco la nuova
sfera
l'ultimo sfera mi ha trasformato in
patina con queste ali quindi se tocco
questa sfera che cosa succederà punti
del copai
[Musica]
va bene tutto master ha memorizzato
ma dove sei
[Musica]
anita sento la tua voce ma non ti vedo
eccoti finalmente ma cos'è questa una
zanzara sì lo so è stata la volta
cattivo la strega è stata la patetica
quello dentro la sfera di cristallo è
arrivato il caldo tu sei sparito
mi ha fatto toccare il mio portale spero
piccola che adesso come facciamo a farti
tornare normale non lo so dobbiamo
trovare il modo di farmi tornare normale
non posso rimanere così per sempre
corta e vita invero siano
partiti bilanci d'altro nuova forma
sarà ancora più difficile corri superare
le mie prove
con questa giorno formale budaj pari
amici via colle vr mi
vieni salì sulla mia mano sicura di
voler andare da sola in giardino
potrebbe essere pericoloso il promo può
essere pericoloso per visto lo colpì
piccola
sono fornito una cucina
e va bene ti porto ma stai attento a
preoccupare
attenta
ok allora ti lascio qui va bene allora
io ritorno a cercare gli altri zaini se
hai bisogno di aiuto chiamami a più
tardi ciao
berlino ma river gigante
che cos'è questo tumore
[Applauso]
30 punto nemmeno come sempre da questo
altro non solo che arrivi l'italia
la vita come sei
veramente
ma dove io ei fosse qui ti stavo
cercando mi stavo preoccupando
la fata
e va bene ma state bene attenti perché
la prossima prova sarà molto più
difficile
[Musica]
da grande finalmente
marino sei tu
[Musica]
c'è qualcuno con camera
vi
[Musica]
passato qualcuno
c'è nessuno
[Musica]
no
se qualcuno qua sotto la scrivania
[Musica]
non c'è niente
provo berlino contro volta
c'è qualcosa
bravo contro un bel berlino
se qualcuno qua
[Musica]
sto aspettando la prossima prova ma la
sfera non parla più non so che cosa devo
fare adesso
forse la prova è già iniziata ma la
sfera grande non era sparita
brava ma avete visto anche voi una
presenza strana
lasciate un mi piace se anche poi la
parte vista
adesso con questi rumori
c'è qualcuno dentro l'armadio
migliore vitale
prima che esca fuori qualcosa
dall'armadio
tale
aiuta
c'è qualcuno qua
mi dà le
semplici ma tutti finalmente
guarda che cosa
aspetta guarda ti guardo
c'è una sorpresa per me nell'armadio non
aprirla nuovo aprirlo per berlino lo sta
per che ha visto tutto nero berlino che
tu hai visto l'arma che il sistema
momento si stava muovendo si stava
muovendo da solo e non ci aver ruote
questo nome le ante dell'armadio temo
che cosa c'è tempo no no no no può
essere pericoloso se nessuno strano
mette ogni volta che arrivi tu mettono
le cose
paranormali comunque stavo osservando la
sfera tutti i ricordi che la sfera
grande fosse qua qua sopra no era stato
sostituito da quella piccola fatti ma
ora ci sono tutte e due ok va bene
mentre tu cerchi di risolvere questo
mistero io ritorno a cucinare
pensi ad altro
bene ho deciso che mi metterò qua
davanti all'armadio a controllare se
succede qualcosa costa non succede più
niente
forse la presenza si è spostata e non è
più
dentro l'armadio se sentite un rumore
strano e solo berlino che su grano che
ai suoi giocattoli
e berlino quando smetti mai di
sgranocchiare
tantissimi fermate un momento
è sentito
[Musica]
chi lo fa è un po di silenzio tono non
riesco a sentire il rumore
[Musica]
ma tu
che
dici che dovrei controllare perché no
che cosa faccio non penso che sia una
buona idea aprire l'armadio anche perché
potrebbe spuntare fuori qualsiasi cosa
forse devo prendere la sfera è provare a
ricontattare la fata bello
e buono non vedo l'ora di mangiarvi
tutto
da
rita e ripeti succede di ho sentito
urlare
vita
sanità
ehi ma sei lassù
ci fai lassù
piace farla su
[Musica]
radio
mi è successo
jamila tra la
se qualcosa nell'armadio mi ha strappato
una cosa quarta
deve guardare la dentro ok però
preparati
prendi qualcosa per catturarlo
ok tu nasconditi ci penso io non ti
preoccupare nasconditi casomai viene a
cercarti di nuovo io non posso
avvicinarmi altrimenti mi strapperò
anche l'altra dai molto ha detto ok non
ti preoccupare adesso ci penso io
nasconditi nasconditi ok ci penso io qui
non guardando qua dietro si si io ti
affermerò d'acqua va bene stai attenta
che
cosa posso prendere
una penna
un evidenziatore
una paletta ma che ci faccio con la
paletta
uno specchio
la spaventa 11 specchio
lusso di berlino si sono stati parti
contesta no mi stai portando male tiene
corso da che cosa possa cercare
idea
un righello
ti aiuterò con un righello ok vediamo
non sento niente
[Musica]
chi c'è nell'armadio
scivoli
coraggio
[Musica]
si
no ecco chi in mano posso capirlo ci
siamo già incontrati che ho fatto
sparire manchi il cuore certo che mi
ricordo io ti è bastato
ma quindi noi occhi da serpente
spaventosi all'ostico ho visto
nell'armadio di chi erano
[Musica]
ma tu assomigli al no no niente niente
niente niente niente non voglio farmi
arrabbiare
subito dove a partire da dove la sera
era
piccola fatina la sfera ma che costa e
dicendo io non ho visto nessuno fatti da
un'oscura sulla sfera non conosco
nessuna fatica non ho visto nessuna ha
sentito rumori
quel rumore no cm libri che sto
sgranocchiando il suo ossigeno
ma
perché sei venuta qui allora perché
l'altra volta vissero divertito
tantissimo a trasformare la pagina in un
insetto ha riempito la di urbani quindi
deciso di tornare trasformare in un
impeto anche
berlino si può trasformare tutti per
presto ormai ho bisogno della era
piccola di nome di bini dove la mattina
la sfera piccola la fatina io non ho
visto fatichino a oxford piccole boh non
lo so se sicura magari ti stai
confondendo
e non mi visiste ubicato nella frattini
la satira è innovativa uscita sai e
penso che non riuscirai a trovarla
perché è uscita già da parecchio tempo e
guarda ma io ti consiglio perché magari
non torni da dove sei venuto oppure
ritorna nell'armadio fi invitantissimo
le facciano
un rumore che rumore non sentito niente
io
sono molti spalti non c'e nessun accesso
ora guarda non c'è nessuno qui e
ti ho detto che sono da solo
[Musica]
giorno non c'e niente portiere nocerina
aspetta aspetta aspettati di voto quella
sfera allora la sfera e medicamenti
leader e ti spiego dove siccome noi
avevamo molto paura di quella sfera che
abbiamo preso con una coperta
abbiamo fatto un buco in giardino
l'abbiamo l'abbiamo sepolta in giardino
secondo il giardino
e si sdoppia paura abbiamo paura e
quindi l'abbiamo messa lì lo abbiamo
preso con una coperta per non toccarla
con le mani
[Musica]
potevo fare qualcosa ma che cosa
chi disegna una mappa con il percorso da
seguire praticamente per andare
esattamente
dovesse volta la sfera così potrei
scavare e trovare la tua sfera va bene
se si sente la faccia subito
vediamo qui un attimo è sto facendo
ci sta impiegando un po perché la stato
disegnato tutta la precisa amano o che
riguarda ecco la mappa
come non si capisce
tu sei qui e di vietare o fare devi fare
lo slalom tra gli alberi e poi
praticamente arrivi a questo punto e te
ne accorgi perché al terzo albero tra il
terzo e il quarto albero però sul terzo
albero c'è la pala per scavare quindi
così in futuro tra il terzo al quarto
potrei scavare e scavando scavando
scavando potrei trovare la tua il tuo
forziere
scusa non un forziere ho sbagliato e la
sfera piccola troverai qui va bene
prendere la mia
[Musica]
chiude a chiave qua dentro
ma
c'è chiuso chiave qua dentro sì sono
riuscito a farlo uscire alita poi uscire
fuori adesso dai vieni ma sei impazzito
ma che razza di piano è questo
cosa c'è che non va al piano che ho
fatto sono riuscito a farlo allontanare
adesso possiamo scappare insieme e non
credo geniale lo distratta così noi nel
frattempo possiamo scappare pescava
guarda
come cosa c'è che non va non appena
scoprirà che la sfera non è sotterrata
in giardino tornerà e sarà
arrabbiatissima e in più non possiamo
neanche scappare perché ha chiuso la
porta a chiave
effettivamente non ci avevo pensato
a noi per caso una seconda chiave
un'altra chiave nascosta da qualche
parte così magari riusciamo ad uscire no
che non ho una chiave di emergenza però
ascolta o un piano mentre voi due
stavate parlando elaborato un piano che
spero tanto che funzioni però è molto
rischioso forse abbiamo ancora del tempo
vediamo per fortuna sta ancora scavando
non ha ancora scoperto la verità allora
il piano è questo sentire molto molto
rischiosa e abbiamo pochissimo tempo
quindi ascoltami bene se ciò che di più
lei tra poco rientrerai sarà
arrabbiatissimo perché aveva capito che
le prese in giro quindi mister è molto
molto attento certo sì sì sì ok ok il
mio piano è questo
i
predetti ce l'ho capita
forse bisogna sbagliarlo fosse capitato
non c'è niente
mi sono sbagliato ti ho detto di sì
segno subito un'altra mappa va bene
di vendere i cieli miche protetti di
formica per i miei borghi
per questo che a farla e farla farlo a
meno che non mi dici too big to fail
la
[Musica]
cosa hai fatto dov'è finita la faccia
cattiva e il piano di quel di fornovo ci
sono riuscita ora mettiamo a posto
[Musica]
l'unione penalità
dentista fatah cattiva ora stai cosa si
prova ad essere piccola come un insetto
come
minimo è
ora sai cosa si prova ad essere
rimpiccioliti come un effetto ben detto
che mi pensi vuoi andare a fare
conoscenza con le formiche
sì certo
ali con cui non posso nemmeno volare
infatti me lei donate solo per punizione
amen ieri anche strappato una mi
dispiace per te fatta cattiva è giunta
la tua bene
[Applauso]
[Musica]
beh in effetti potremmo pensarci
no la disparità si no mi sento molto
meglio finalmente però io non mi fido
molto della fazione a orentano di felice
giornata normale
liberatevi di
un'idea un'idea ti guardo io
ecco qua
vecchio di questa gara non esulta là
dentro
prova ora tu a superare questa prova
fatina code baia a trattare male le
persone capito
[Applauso]
un
pericoloso minacciarci rifiuto l'idea
sai aspetta
[Applauso]
ora che ha imparato la lezione direi che
possiamo liberarla che ne pensi
spetta liberarla forse no potrebbe
ancora essere pericolosa però ora che ci
penso è prova a non aver paura
noi non abbiamo più paura di lei quindi
è vero non abbiamo più paura perché
l'abbiamo rimpicciolita quindi ce ne
possiamo liberare rimettendo nella
scatola da dove è uscita no
non abbiamo più paura di lei perché
l'abbiamo rimpicciolita proviamo a
rimetterla nella scatola e vediamo se
scompare
chiudiamo e aspettiamo sì
contro le adesso vedi si è sparita
il tiro un po di paura di aprire trovare
qualcos'altro tu che ne pensi marino
non c'è niente
mi raccomando però non aprire mai più
quella scatola e non prendere mai nessun
oggetto da quella scatola ok me lo
prometti va bene te lo prometto ma
l'importante chiara abbiamo vincere
[Musica]